russia says some of its troops involved
in military drills near ukraine are
pulling back and returning to their
bases after completing the exercises the
drills have been a significant factor in
the crisis between russia and ukraine
which along with western nations fear
moscow is planning an invasion
on monday the kremlin suggested
diplomacy is still possible in diffusing
the standoff
let's go straight to dorset jabari's
live for us in moscow so tell us a bit
more about
these russian forces that are returning
to their bases
is it significant
well it certainly is and we've just been
hearing from the chief spokesperson of
the russian defense ministry major
general igor konoshenkov who has issued
a statement saying that some of russia's
western and southern military units will
be on their way back to their home bases
upon completing a series of military
maneuvers the major general also went on
to say that there are other further
units that are finishing up their
military drills and will be
going back to their home bases this is
of course something we heard from the
russian defense minister on monday
sergey shougo at a meeting with the
russian president vladimir putin said
that this was about to take place that
the military drills that were ongoing
for the past few weeks were coming to an
end and most of the military units that
have been dispatched alongside the
country's borders will be returning to
their home bases of course this will be
seen as the first significant step in
the current situation that we're in and
possibly seen as a sign of russia really
de-escalating the situation and sticking
to the word saying that these uh troop
movements were all to carry out these
drills and now that they're rebasing
them they really are going back to where
they were in the beginning and
reiterating this country's position that
they never really intended to invade
ukraine this was just a hysteria
narrative that was built by the western
countries
well perhaps the days and days of
diplomacy
is leading to something we have more
diplomacy today with the german
chancellor arriving in russia or already
in russia we're not 100 sure yet
what are we expecting from meetings
between schultz and putin today
well the german chancellor will be
talking about three main things with the
russian president first trying to
de-escalate the current crisis with
ukraine
and second on the agenda we'll be
talking about uh the security guarantees
that russia is looking for when it comes
to nato's further expansion and then the
third will be talking about that very
important uh north stream two gas
pipeline that was an 11 billion project
that took russian gas from siberia
transferred to
germany via the sea and not bypassing
any specific country this is a project
that was completed in september but has
yet to become operational due to certain
restrictions placed on it by the german
government many here accuse
germany of turning this pipeline into a
geopolitical tool the german chancellor
will certainly be discussing this with
the russian president and of course this
is not the only meeting that is taking
place here today the russian foreign
minister sergey lavrov will also
is currently meeting with his polish
counterpart the polish foreign minister
is in moscow to hold meetings about the
current situation and the
osce's concerns when it comes to the
current crisis that is ongoing so there
is still very much a diplomatic path
that is being pursued by many sides and
this latest announcement by the russian
defense ministry will certainly be an
important one given uh the day that
we're having in moscow the diplomatic
push to try and de-escalate the tensions
okay thank you for that daughter jabari
there for us live in moscow we can turn
now to step vassen who's live in pinsk
which is in western belarus where russia
has been holding some of the drills uh
steph i wonder what you can see where
you are especially in light of the fact
that russia says some of the troops that
have been involved in military drills
are now being pulled back
yes i'm mean pins that's uh 30
kilometers from the ukrainian border and
this uh historical town has quite a a
big population from uh ukrainians so
there's a lot of concern here also at
this border about its russian military
exercises happening so nearby the
belarusian authorities have released
some locations where these joint drills
are still ongoing but since uh yesterday
i have to say we've been traveling
around this region the southern border
of belarus with ukraine and it was very
quiet there was supposed to be exercises
air defense
fighter jets in actions even
bombardments at a place not very far
from here but so far it's very difficult
to see that there's a very large-scale
military exercise ongoing meanwhile of
course we know that
russia is now saying that they have
finished these exercises or are
finishing up these exercises and are
withdrawing troops we haven't seen any
signs of that but it could mean that
definitely these exercises are closing
and there's not much activity here but
people are telling us here they're not
very optimistic that russian forces will
leave that soon and they're quite
worried that the russians are actually
using this military exercise as a
pretext to basically occupy belarus and
have permanent bases here and that's
something that a lot of belarusians are
definitely not agreeing with
okay many thanks for that step vassen
monitoring the situation from pinsk in
western belarus